The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: To begin today
I want to remind you,
I need to write it down on
the board at least twice,
of the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
We called it FTC 1 because
it's the first version
of the fundamental theorem.
We'll be talking about
another version, called
the second version, today.
And what it says
is this: If F' = f,
then the integral from a to b
of f(x) dx is equal to F(b) -
F(a).
So that's the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
And the way we used
it last time was,
this was used to
evaluate integrals.
Not surprisingly,
that's how we used it.
But today, I want to
reverse that point of view.
We're going to read
the equation backwards,
and we're going to
write it this way.
And we're going to use f
to understand capital F.
Or in other words,
the derivative
to understand the function.
So that's the reversal of point
of view that I'd like to make.
And we'll make this
point in various ways.
So information about
f, about F', gives us
information about F. Now,
since there were questions
about the mean
value theorem, I'm
going to illustrate
this first by making
a comparison between the
fundamental theorem of calculus
and the mean value theorem.
So we're going to compare this
fundamental theorem of calculus
with what we call the
mean value theorem.
And in order to
do that, I'm going
to introduce a
couple of notations.
I'll write delta
F as F(b) - F(a).
And another highly imaginative
notation, delta x = b - a.
So here's the change in F,
there's the change in x.
And then, this
fundamental theorem
can be written, of course, right
up above there is the formula.
And it's the
formula for delta F.
So this is what we call
the fundamental theorem
of calculus.
I'm going to divide
by delta x, now.
And If I divide by delta x,
that's the same thing as 1 /
(b-a) times the integral
from a to b of f(x) dx.
So I've just rewritten
the formula here.
And this expression here,
on the right-hand side,
is a fairly important one.
This is the average of f.
That's the average value of f.
Now, so this is
going to permit me
to make the comparison between
the mean value theorem, which
we don't have stated yet here.
And the fundamental theorem.
And I'll do it in the
form of inequalities.
So right in the
middle here, I'm going
to put the fundamental theorem.
It says that delta F in
this notation is equal to,
well if I multiply
by delta x again, I
can write it as
the average of f--
So I'm going to write it
as the average of F' here.
Times delta x.
So we have this
factor here, which
is the average of F', or
the average of little f,
it's the same thing.
And then I multiplied
through again.
So I put the thing
in the red box, here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Isn't what
the average of big F?
So the question is,
why is this the average
of little f rather than
the average of big F.
So the average of a function
is the typical value.
If, for example,
little f were constant,
little f were constant, then
this integral would be--
So the question is why
is this the average.
And I'll take a little
second to explain that.
But I think I'll
explain it over here.
Because I'm going to erase it.
So the idea of an
average is the following.
For example, imagine
that a = 0 and b = n,
let's say for example.
And so we might sum the
function from 1 to n.
Now, that would be the sum
of the values from 1 to n.
But the average is,
we divide by n here.
So this is the average.
And this is a kind
of Riemann sum,
representing the integral
from 0 to n, of f(x) dx.
Where the increment,
delta x, is 1.
So this is the notion of
an average value here,
but in the continuum
setting, as opposed
to the discrete setting.
Whereas what's on
the left-hand side
is the change in
F. The capital F.
And this is the average
of the little f.
So an average is a sum.
And it's like an integral.
So, in other words what I have
here is that the change in F
is the average of its
infinitesimal change
times the amount of time
elapsed, if you like.
So this is the statement
of the fundamental theorem.
Just rewritten.
Exactly what I wrote there.
But I multiplied
back by delta x.
Now, let me compare this
with the mean value theorem.
The mean value theorem
also is an equation.
The mean value theorem says that
this is equal to F'(c) delta x.
Now, I pulled a fast one on you.
I used capital F's here
to make the analogy clear.
But the role of the letter
is important to make
the transition to
this comparison.
We're talking about the
function capital F here.
And its derivative.
Now, this is true.
So now I claim that this
thing is fairly specific.
Whereas this, unfortunately,
is a little bit vague.
And the reason why it's vague
is that c is just somewhere
in the interval.
So some c-- Sorry, this is
some c, in between a and b.
So really, since we don't
know where this thing is,
we don't know
which of the values
it is, we can't say what it is.
All we can do is
say, well for sure
it's less than
the largest value,
say, the maximum of
F', times delta x.
And the only thing we can
say for sure on the other end
is that it's less than
or equal to-- sorry,
it's greater than or
equal to the minimum
of F' times delta x.
Over that same interval.
This is over 0 less
than-- sorry, a < x < b.
So that means that the
fundamental theorem of calculus
is a much more specific thing.
And indeed it gives
the same conclusion.
It's much stronger than
the mean value theorem.
It's way better than
In fact, as soon as
we have integrals,
we can abandon the
mean value theorem.
We don't want it.
It's too simple-minded.
And what we have is something
much more sophisticated,
which we can use.
Which is this.
So it's obvious that
if this is the average,
the average is less
than the maximum.
So it's obvious that
it works just as well
to draw this conclusion.
And similarly over
here with the minimum.
OK, the average is always
bigger than the minimum
and smaller than the max.
So this is the
connection, if you like.
And I'm going to elaborate just
one step further by talking
about the problem that
you had on the exam.
So there was an Exam 2 problem.
And I'll show you how it works
using the mean value theorem
and how it works
using integrals.
But I'm going to have to
use this notation capital F.
So capital F', as
opposed to the little f,
which was what was the
notation that was on your exam.
So we had this situation here.
These were the givens
of the problem.
And then the question was,
the mean value theorem says,
or implies, if you
like, it doesn't say it,
but it implies it - implies
A is less than capital F of 4
is less than B,
for which A and B?
So let's take a look
at what it says.
Well, the mean value
theorem says that F( F(4) -
F(0) = F'(c) (4 - 0).
This is this F' times delta
x, this is the change in x.
And that's the same
thing as 1/(1+c) times 4.
And so the range of values
of this number here is from /
1/(1+0) times 4, that's 4.
To, that's the largest value,
to the smallest that it gets,
which is 1/(1+4) times 4.
That's the range.
And so the conclusion is that
F(4) - f(0) is between, well,
let's see.
It's between 4 and 4/5.
Which are those two
numbers down there.
And if you remember
that F(0) was 1,
this is the same F(4)
is between 5 and 9/5.
So that's the way that
you were supposed to solve
the problem on the exam.
On the other hand,
let's compare to what
you would do with the
fundamental theorem
of calculus.
With the fundamentals
theorem of calculus,
we have the following formula.
F(4) - F(0) is equal to the
integral from 0 to 4 of dx /
(1+x).
That's what the
fundamental theorem says.
And now I claim that we can
get these same types of results
by a very elementary
observation.
It's really the same
observation that I made up here,
that the average is less
than or equal to the maximum.
Which is that the biggest this
can ever be is, let's see.
The biggest it is
when x is 0, that's 1.
So the biggest it
ever gets is this.
And that's equal to 4.
Right?
On the other hand, the
smallest it ever gets to be,
it's equal to this.
The smallest it ever gets
to be is the integral
from 0 to 4 of 1/5 dx.
Because that's the lowest
value that the integrand takes.
When x = 4, it's 1/5.
And that's equal to 4/5.
Now, there's a
little tiny detail
which is that really
we know that this
is the area of some rectangle
and this is strictly smaller.
And we know that these
inequalities are actually
strict.
But that's a minor point.
And certainly not one that
we'll pay close attention to.
But now, let me show you what
this looks like geometrically.
So geometrically, we interpret
this as the area under a curve.
Here's a piece of the
curve y = 1/(1+x).
And it's going up to 4
and starting at 0 here.
And the first
estimate that we made
- that is, the upper bound
- was by trapping this
in this big rectangle here.
We compared it to the
constant function,
which was 1 all the way across.
This is y = 1.
And then we also trapped
it from underneath
by the function which
was at the bottom.
And this was y = 1/5.
And so what this really
is is, these things
are the simplest
possible Riemann sum.
Sort of a silly Riemann sum.
This is a Riemann sum
with one rectangle.
This is the simplest
possible one.
And so this is a very,
very crude estimate.
You can see it misses by a mile.
The larger and
the smaller values
are off by a factor of 5.
But this one is called
the-- this one is the lower
Riemann sum.
And that one is less
than our actual integral.
Which is less than
the upper Riemann sum.
And you should, by now, have
looked at those upper and lower
sums on your homework.
So it's just the
rectangles underneath
and the rectangles on top.
So at this point,
we can literally
abandon the mean value theorem.
Because we have a much better
way of getting at things.
If we chop things up
into more rectangles,
we'll get much better
numerical approximations.
And if we use simpleminded
expressions with integrals,
we'll be able to figure
out any bound we could get
using the mean value theorem.
So that's not the relevance
of the mean value theorem.
I'll explain to you why
we talked about it, even,
in a few minutes.
OK, are there any
questions before we go on?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I knew that the
range of c was from 0 to 4,
I should have said
that right here.
This is true for this theorem.
The mean value theorem comes
with an extra statement,
which I missed.
Which is that this is for
some c between 0 and 4.
So I know the range
is between 0 and 4.
The reason why it's
between 0 and 4
is that's part of the
mean value theorem.
We started at 0, we ended at 4.
So the c has to be
somewhere in between.
That's part of the
mean value theorem.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
question is, do you
exclude any values that
are above 4 and below 0.
Yes, absolutely.
The point is that in
order to figure out
how F changes, capital F
changes, between 0 and 4,
you need only pay attention
to the values in between.
You don't have to
pay any attention
to what the function is
doing below 0 or above 4.
Those things are
strictly irrelevant.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
mean it's strictly
in between these two numbers.
I have to understand what the
lowest and the highest one is.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's
approaching that, so.
OK.
So now, the next thing that
we're going to talk about
is, since I've got
that 1 up there,
that Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 1, I
need to talk about version 2.
So here is the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus version 2.
I'm going to start out
with a function little f,
and I'm going to assume
that it's continuous.
And then I'm going to define
a new function, which is
defined as a definite integral.
G(x) is the integral
from a to x of f(t) dt.
Now, I want to emphasize here
because it's the first time
that I'm writing
something like this,
that this is a fairly
complicated gadget.
It plays a very basic and very
fundamental but simple role,
but it nevertheless is
a little complicated.
What's happening here is
that the upper limit I've now
called x, and the variable t
is ranging between a and x,
and that the a and
the x are fixed
when I calculate the integral.
And the t is what's
called the dummy variable.
It's the variable
of integration.
You'll see a lot of people who
will mix this x with this t.
And if you do that,
you will get confused,
potentially hopelessly
confused, in this class.
In 18.02 you will be
completely lost if you do that.
So don't do it.
Don't mix these two guys up.
It's actually done by
many people in textbooks,
and it's fairly careless.
Especially in
old-fashioned textbooks.
But don't do it.
So here we have this G(x).
Now, remember, this G(x)
really does make sense.
If you give me an a,
and you give me an x,
I can figure out what this
is, because I can figure out
the Riemann sum.
So of course I need to know
what the function is, too.
But anyway, we have a numerical
procedure for figuring out
what the function G is.
Now, as is suggested by this
mysterious letter x being
in the place where it is,
I'm actually going to vary x.
So the conclusion is
that if this is true,
and this is just a parenthesis,
not part of the theorem.
It's just an indication of
what the notation means.
Then G' = f.
Let me first explain what the
significance of this theorem
is, from the point of view
of differential equations.
G(x) solves the differential
equation y' = f(x).
So y' = f, I shouldn't put
the x in if I got it here,
with the condition y(a) = 0.
So it solves this pair
of conditions here.
The rate of change, and
the initial position
is specified here.
Because when you integrate
from a to a, you get 0 always.
And what this theorem
says is you can always
solve that equation.
When we did differential
equations, I said that already.
I said we'll treat
these as always solved.
Well, here's the reason.
We have a numerical procedure
for computing things like this.
We could always
solve this equation.
And the formula is a
fairly complicated gadget,
but so far just associated
with Riemann sums.
Alright, now.
Let's just do one example.
Unfortunately, not a complicated
example and maybe not
persuasive as to why you would
care about this just yet.
But nevertheless very important.
Because this is the quiz
question which everybody gets
wrong until they practice it.
So the integral from,
say 1 to x, of dt / t^2.
Let's try this one here.
So here's an example of
this theorem, I claim.
Now, this is a question
which challenges your ability
to understand what
the question means.
Because it's got
a lot of symbols.
It's got the integration and
it's got the differentiation.
However, what it really is
is an exercise in recopying.
You look at it and you
write down the answer.
And the reason is
that, by definition,
this function in here is
a function of the form
G(x) of the theorem over here.
So this is the G(x).
And by definition, we
said that G'(x) = f(x).
Well, what's the f(x)?
Look inside here.
It's what's called
the integrand.
This is the integral from
0 to x of f(t) dt, right?
Where the f(t) is
equal to 1 / t^2.
So your ability is challenged.
You have to take that 1 /
t^2 and you have to plug
in the letter x,
instead of t, for it.
And then write it down.
As I say, this is an exercise
in recopying what's there.
So this is quite
easy to do, right?
I mean, you just look
and you write it down.
But nevertheless, it looks like
a long, elaborate object here.
Pardon me?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question
was, why did I integrate.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did
I not integrate?
Ah.
Very good question.
Why did I not integrate.
The reason why I didn't
integrate is I didn't need to.
Just as when you take the
antiderivative-- sorry,
the derivative of something,
you take the antiderivative,
you get back to the thing.
So, in this case, we're taking
the antiderivative of something
and we're differentiating.
So we end back in the same
place where we started.
We started with f(t),
we're ending with f.
Little f.
So you integrate, and
then differentiate.
And you get back
to the same place.
Now, the only difference between
this and the other version
is, in this case when you
differentiate and integrate
you could be off by a constant.
That's what that
shift, why there
are two pieces to this one.
But there's never
an extra piece here.
There's no plus c here.
When you integrate
and differentiate,
you kill whatever
the constant is.
Because the derivative
of a constant is 0.
So no matter what the constant
is, hiding inside of G,
you're getting the same result.
So this is the basic idea.
Now, I just want
to double-check it,
using the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 1 here.
So let's actually
evaluate the integral.
So now I'm going
to do what you've
suggested, which
is I'm just going
to check whether it's true.
No, no I am because I'm
going just double-check
that it's consistent.
It certainly is slower
this way, and we're not
going to want to do
this all the time,
but we might as well check one.
So this is our integral.
And we know how to do it.
No, I need to do it.
And this is -t^(-1),
evaluated at 1 and x.
Again, there's something
subliminally here
for you to think about.
Which is that, remember, it's t
is ranging between 1 and t = x.
And this is one of the big
reasons why this letter
t has to be different from x.
Because here it's
1 and there it's x.
It's not x.
So you can't put an x here.
Again, this is t = 1 and
this is t = x over there.
And now if I plug
that in, I get what?
I get -1/x, and
then I get -(-1).
So this is, let me get rid
of those little t's there.
This is a little easier to read.
And so now let's check it.
It's d/dx.
So here's what G(x) is.
G(x) = 1 - 1/x.
That's what G(x) is.
And if I differentiate
that, I get +1 / x^2.
That's it.
You see the constant
washed away.
So now, here's my job.
My job is to prove
these theorems.
I never did prove them for you.
So, I'm going to prove
the Fundamental Theorem
of Calculus.
But I'm going to do 2 first.
And then I'm going to do 1.
And it's just going to take
me just one blackboard.
It's not that hard.
The proof is by picture.
And, using the interpretation
as area under the curve.
So if here's the
value of a, and this
is the graph of the
function y equals f of x.
Then I want to draw
three vertical lines.
One of them is going to be at x.
And one of them is going
to be at x + delta x.
So here I have the
interval from 0
to x, and next I have the
interval from x to delta
x more than that.
And now the pieces that I've
got are the area of this part.
So this has area
which has a name.
It's called G(x).
By definition, G(x), which
is sitting right over here
in the fundamental theorem,
is the integral from a
to x of this function.
So it's the area
under the curve.
So that area is G(x).
Now this other
chunk here, I claim
that this is delta G. This
is the change in G. It's
the value of G(x) that is the
area of the whole business all
the way up to x + delta x
minus the first part, G(x).
So it's what's left over.
It's the incremental
amount of area there.
And now I am going to carry out
a pretty standard estimation
here.
This is practically a rectangle.
And it's got a base of delta
x, and so we need to figure out
what its height is.
This is delta G, and it's
approximately its base
times its height.
But what is the height?
Well, the height is maybe either
this segment or this segment
or something in between.
But they're all about the same.
So I'm just going to put in
the value at the first point.
That's the left end there.
So that's this
height here, is f(x).
So this is f(x), and so
really I approximate it
by that rectangle there.
And now if I divide
and take the limit,
as delta x goes to 0,
of delta G / delta x,
it's going to equal f(x).
And this is where I'm using
the fact that f is continuous.
Because I need the
values nearby to be
similar to the
value in the limit.
OK, that's the end.
This the end of the proof, so
I'll put a nice little Q.E.D.
here.
So we've done Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 2,
and now we're ready for
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus
1.
So now I still have it on
the blackboard to remind you.
It says that the integral
of the derivative
is the function, at least the
difference between the values
of the function at two places.
So the place where we start is
with this property that F' = f.
That's the starting--
that's the hypothesis.
Now, unfortunately,
I'm going to have
to assume something
extra in order
to use the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 2,
which is I'm going to
assume that f is continuous.
That's not really
necessary, but that's
just a very minor
technical point,
which I'm just going to ignore.
So we're going to
start with F' = f.
And then I'm going
to go somewhere else.
I'm going to define
a new function, G(x),
which is the integral
from a to x of f(t) dt.
This is where we needed all
of the labor of Riemann sums.
Because otherwise we don't
have a way of making sense out
of what this even means.
So hiding behind
this one sentence
is the fact that we
actually have a number.
We have a formula
for such functions.
So there is a
function G(x) which,
once you've produced
a little f for me,
I can cook up a function
capital G for you.
Now, we're going to apply this
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus
2, the one that we've
already checked.
So what does it say?
It says that G' = f.
And so now we're in the
following situation.
We know that F'(x) = G'(x).
That's what we've got so far.
And now we have one last step to
get a good connection between F
and G. Which is that we
can conclude that F(x)
is G(x) plus a constant.
Now, this little step
may seem innocuous
but I remind you that this
is the spot that requires
the mean value theorem.
So in order not to lie
to you, we actually
tell you what the underpinnings
of all of calculus are.
And they're this: the
fact, if you like,
that if two functions
have the same derivative,
they differ by a constant.
Or that if a function
has derivative 0,
it's a constant itself.
Now, that is the fundamental
step that's needed,
the underlying
step that's needed.
And, unfortunately, there
aren't any proofs of it
that are less complicated than
using the mean value theorem.
And so that's why we talk a
little bit about the mean value
theorem, because we don't want
to lie to you about what's
really going on.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is how
did I get from here, to here.
And the answer is that
if G' is little f,
and we also know that F'
is little f, then F' is G'.
OK.
Other questions?
Alright, so we're almost done.
I just have to work out
the arithmetic here.
So I start with F(b) - F(a).
And that's equal to
(G(b) + c) - (G(a) + c).
And then I cancel the c's.
So I have here G(b) - G(a).
And now I just have to
check what each of these is.
So remember the
definition of G here.
G(b) is just what we want.
The integral from
a to b of f(x) dx.
Well I called it f(t) dt,
that's the same as f(x) dx
now, because I have
the limit being b
and I'm allowed to use
x as the dummy variable.
Now the other one,
I claim, is 0.
Because it's the
integral from a to a.
This one is the
Which gives us 0.
So this is just this minus
0, and that's the end.
That's it.
I started with F(b) - F(a),
I got to the integral.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How did I get from
F(b) - F(a), is (G(b) + c) -
(G(a) + c), that's the question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry
this is an equals sign.
Sorry, the second
line didn't draw.
OK, equals.
Because we're plugging in,
for F(x), the formula for it.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This step here?
Or this one?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that was a good question.
But the answer is that
that's the statement
that we're aiming for.
That's the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 1,
which we don't know yet.
So we're trying to prove it,
and that's why we haven't, we
can't assume it.
OK, so let me just notice that
in the example that we had,
before we go on to
something else here.
In the example above, what we
had was the following thing.
We had, say, F(x) = -1/x.
So F'(x) = 1 / x^2.
And, say, G(x) = 1 - 1/x.
And you can see that
either way you do that,
if you integrate from
1 to 2, let's say,
which is what we had
over there, dt / t^2,
you're going to get either -1/t,
1 to 2, or, if you like, 1 -
1/t, 1 to 2.
So this is the F version,
this is the G version.
And that's what plays itself
out here, in this general proof.
Alright.
So now I want to go back to
the theme for today, which
is using little f to understand
capital F. In other words,
using the derivative of F
to understand capital F.
And I want to illustrate it by
some more complicated examples.
So I guess I just erased it, but
we just took the antiderivative
of 1 / t^2.
And there's-- all of the
powers work easily, but one.
And the tricky one
is the power 1 / x.
So let's consider the
differential equation L' (x) =
1 / x.
And say, with the
initial value L(1) = 0.
The solution, so the Fundamental
Theorem of Calculus 2
tells us the solution
is this function here.
L(x) equals the integral
from 1 to x, dt / t.
That's how we solve
all such equations.
We just integrate, take
the definite integral.
And I'm starting at 1 because
I insisted that L(1) be 0.
So that's the solution
to the problem.
And now the thing
that's interesting here
is that we started
from a polynomial.
Or we started from a rational,
a ratio of polynomials;
that is, 1 / t or 1 / x.
And we get to a function
which is actually
what's known as a
transcendental function.
It's not an algebraic function.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is
why is this equal to that.
And the answer is, it's
for the same reason
that this is equal to that.
It's the same reason as this.
It's that the 1's cancel.
We've taken the value of
something at 2 minus the value
at 1.
The value at 2 minus
the value at 1.
And you'll get a 1 in the
one case, and you get a 1
in the other case.
And you subtract them
and they will cancel.
They'll give you 0.
These two things
really are equal.
This is not a function
evaluated at one place,
it's the difference between
the function evaluated
at 2 and the value at 1.
And whenever you subtract
two things like that,
constants drop out.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If I put 2 here,
if I put c here,
it would have been the same.
It would just have dropped out.
It's not there.
And that's exactly this
arithmetic right here.
It doesn't matter which
antiderivative you take.
When you take the differences,
the c's will cancel.
You always get the
same answer in the end.
That's exactly why
I wrote this down,
so that you would see that.
It doesn't matter
which one you do.
So, we still have a couple
of minutes left here.
This is actually--
So let me go back.
So here's the antiderivative
of 1 / x, with value 1 at 0.
Now, in disguise, we know
what this function is.
We know this function is
the logarithm function.
But this is actually
a better way
of deriving all of the
formulas for the logarithm.
This is a much quicker and
more efficient way of doing it.
We had to do it by very
laborious processes.
This will allow us
to do it very easily.
And so, I'm going to
do that next time.
But rather than do
that now, I'm going
to point out to you that we can
also get truly new functions.
OK, so there are all
kinds of new functions.
So this is the first example
of this kind would be,
for example, to solve the
equation y' = e^(-x^2) with
y(0) = 0, let's say.
Now, the solution to
that is a function
which again I can write down
by the fundamental theorem.
It's the integral from
0 to x of e^(-t^2) dt.
This is a very famous function.
This shape here is
known as the bell curve.
And it's the thing that comes
up in probability all the time.
This shape e^(-x^2).
And our function is
geometrically just the area
under the curve here.
This is F(x).
If this place is x.
So I have a
geometric definition,
I have a way of constructing
what it is by Riemann sums.
And I have a function here.
But the curious thing about
F(x) is that F(x) cannot be
expressed in terms of
any function you've seen
previously.
So logs, exponentials,
trig functions, cannot be.
It's a totally new function.
Nevertheless, we'll
be able to get
any possible piece of
information we would want to,
out of this function.
It's perfectly
acceptable function,
it will work just great for us.
Just like any other function.
Just like the log.
And what this is analogous to
is the following kind of thing.
If you take the circle, the
ancient Greeks, if you like,
already understood that if you
have a circle of radius 1, then
its area is pi.
So that's a geometric
construction
of what you could
call a new number.
Which is outside of the realm
of what you might expect.
And the weird thing
about this number pi
is that it is not the root
of an algebraic equation
with rational coefficients.
It's what's called
transcendental.
Meaning, it's just completely
outside of the realm
of algebra.
And, indeed, the
logarithm function
is called a
transcendental function,
because it's completely out
of the realm of algebra.
It's only in calculus
that you come up
with this kind of thing.
So these kinds of
functions will have access
to a huge class of new
functions here, all of which
are important tools in
science and engineering.
So, see you next time.